we are celebrating summer today and i
think we all deserve
rest relaxation and a change of scenery
this year
uh my next guest has us covered with all
sorts of great escapes you can take to
splash into summer and feel good about
doing it
let's welcome back the travel mama
herself emily kaufman everybody
hi everybody hey jelly it's good to be
back with you you look
beautiful like i love the dress the hair
everything the lipstick it looks so
great
um so people still have some reluctance
about traveling right now right
you know they do the number one question
is whether it's safe to get out there
and travel
and the good news is that destinations
and hotels
have created great protocol and
procedures in place
to keep us safe and i've got some trip
options
that will suit everybody's comfort level
all right all right don't threaten us
with a good time okay let's start with
the most conservative travelers
uh what do you suggest you know there
are people that still are not ready to
get on a plane and i totally understand
that
and a great way that you could travel
right now is an rv
vacation an rv vacation is ideal because
you're limiting your interaction with
other people
you're with your family that you've been
in your bubble with but you're getting
outside instead of being indoors with
work and school and all the stuff that
goes along with it you're outside having
some fun
and many campsites and national parks
are following covid protocol as well
with limiting the number of vehicles
that can come on and the number of
people
and you want to make sure that you're
looking to rent an rv with a great
company like rv share
rv share is the first and largest
peer-to-peer platform that connects
rv renters with rv owners and they've
got more than a hundred
thousand vehicles to choose from and you
can do things like be rustic and get off
the grid
or stay at a glamping place something
like a sun rv resort
they've got more than 160 locations
throughout the united states and canada
and one tip to remember you need
reservations ahead of time you can't
just show up at a campsite
and summer's the busiest time so plan
ahead absolutely especially now if
there's limited amount of space
exactly i love this vacation if it were
pandemic times or not it sounds awesome
um well good news emily is not just
telling us about ideal vacations
she is actually helping us give some
away today so
anyone in the house seems interested in
an rv getaway this summer
anybody yeah okay let's do some takers
all right
let's get our light show shuffle
underway right now when i say
go the lights will flash on random
audience members until one lands on
someone
uh whoever stops whoever it stops on
rather is getting the ultimate family
vacation
which includes five thousand dollars
towards a luxury rv rental of your
choice
from rv share and this will cover your
luxury motorhome food
and gas plus you're going to get to stay
at
sun rv resort which is awesome so let's
get to this joe are you ready
all right all right and go
where's it gonna stop when's it gonna
stop oh where's it gonna stop was it
hey okay look at him
[Applause]
what's what's your name and have you
ever done rv traveling before
i know
oh my gosh jocelyn i love you right now
and i kind of want to go on your
vacation with you
you seem fun
i have a family of four and two little
ones and ever since toy story four
they have wanted to go on an rv and this
is amazing thank you so much
absolutely oh my gosh have so much fun i
love you
she's so excited all right well emily
what's next
you know a lot of people are ready to
get on a plane and they're doing it
safely with masks and
and shields and following the protocol
and a great getaway
in the united states it's as tropical as
you can get
while still feeling the arms of uncle
sam wrap tightly around you
is hawaii yeah why leia maui is as
tropical as you can get and it's a nice
easy non-stop plane ride from
so many places hawaii is one of the top
destinations being booked
and wai lei is a great walkable
community on the south shore
of maui and the fairmont kailani is a
great example of a hotel
that's implemented terrific protocol in
place with interactions like things like
contactless check-ins deep cleaning and
those kind of things
my husband and i went there for our 30th
anniversary
and had a blast it's located on the
coveted south shore of maui
in hawaii in wailea and it's hawaii's
only all-suite
with with villa and luxury oceanfront
rooms
and they've been known for their
distinctive dining venues
bars gourmet market three pools
a comprehensive spa and wellness program
and authentic hawaiian culture
plus unrivaled access to one of the best
adventures and beaches across the island
and when you're planning your trip to
hawaii
really important to remember they
require a safe
health application and screening process
so you have to have a negative covenant
test
uploaded 72 hours before you board your
flight so you can go to their website to
check that out at gohawaii.com
yeah that's smart keeping everybody safe
while having a good time um
so no one wants to go to hawaii here
right no one would be interested in that
right
no okay you are okay cool um
well this is for a six day luxury
vacation to the fairmont
kelani in waialea maui
and it includes an ocean view suite
daily breakfast for two
a poolside cabana which i love dinner
for two at co
an airfare provided by the wailea resort
association
uh so let's give away another trip so
joe hit it
go
where's it gonna land where's they're
gonna land
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so what's what's your name and
are
you excited have you ever been to hawaii
no i haven't but
uh my name is julia um my husband and i
are actually coming up on an anniversary
so we
we thought about hawaii oh my well you
know what i am a genie today and your
wish is granted
um all right well enjoy it girl hey
thank you so much
emily for today this was awesome thank
you absolutely absolutely and
congratulations 30 years that's amazing
thanks
yes absolutely want more fun stuff i
thought so
check out these videos floating around
my head this one is really cool
i'm just saying no pressure